Pflanzen als
superhelden forschungsteams weltweit setzen große hoffnungen in das themengebiet grüne gentechnik und die neueste technologie in diesem bereich das neue
wunderwerk zeugt der gentechnik vielleicht sogar der
unbegrenzten möglichkeiten die gehen schere krispl das ergebnis pflanzen die sich selbst gegen schädlinge schützen und dem klimawandel trotzen
Ob diese technologie die menschheit vor dem hungertod retten wird oder ob sie ganze
Ökosysteme ausrotten wird jetzt in klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Die gegenwehr christa ist eine riesige revolution in der wissenschaft da sind sich die forschungsteams weltweit einig ähnlich wie die entdeckung
Der dna damals wissenschaftlich korrekt spricht man vom chris podcast neuen system über das wäre ja schon ab und zu mal berichtet haben
es steht für cluster treasury inter spaceopal
andronic repeats also frei übersetzt so viel wie
kurze abschnitte sich wiederholender dna bakterien nutzen krispl als eine art schutz gegen viren denn es schneidet erbgut also dna
An einer bestimmten stelle und das sehr präzise die bakterien nutzen diese technik also ganz natürlich sie schneiden ds dna
Aus angreifenden wären heraus und setzten sie in die eigene dna ein dadurch erkennen sie die viren beim zukünftigen
Angriff und können sich gegen sie wären diese technik kann aber auch von den technikern genutzt werden um erbgut zu verändern
Und es ist damit
superleicht bestimmte gene können aus dem genom herausgeschnitten werden und neue abschnitte an dieser schnittstelle
eingefügt werden und das tolle daran das ganze funktioniert nicht nur bakterien sondern auch in anderen organismen manche bezeichnen
dass christa system deswegen auch als ein werkzeug der
unbegrenzten möglichkeiten ja und diese technologie die ist nicht nur
Im bereich der grünen gentechnik der große hoffnungsträger auch andere herausforderungen wie die therapie von krebs oder erbkrankheiten
Könnten mithilfe dieser technologie gelöst werden so die hoffnung
Vieler und einen wirklichen haken hat sie tatsächlich auf den ersten blick einmal nicht, im gegenteil
im vergleich zu bisherigen techniken ist sie deutlich schneller und kostengünstiger
denn gene gezielt
Zu verändern das ist nicht neu es gibt zum beispiel die sogenannte sync finger nuklearen zf n also
künstlich hergestellte enzyme die
Dna-sequenzen erkennen und gezielt zerschneiden doch ihre herstellung ist teuer und komplex. Im jahr 2012 haben zwei
molekularbiologin dass kris peeters neuen system zum ersten mal beschrieben
der anfang der revolution und für die beiden forscherinnen vielleicht ein riesenschritt in richtung norbert preis wie gesagt
setzen viele
Forschungsbereiche groß zur hoffnung in die neue technologie unter anderem auch die
pflanzenforschung bzw züchtung champignons die nicht mehr braun werden egal wie lange sie herum liegen seit
2016 tatsächlich in den usa zugelassen und in den supermärkten, zu kaufen
klingt erst einmal toll
Doch wie genau können wir dann feststellen wie frisch der pilz noch ist und es gibt weitere ideen für pflanzen die mit hilfe der gen
chirurgie ja
optimiert werden können erdnüsse die auch allergiker vertragen oder melonen ohne lästige kerne
beispielsweise das gebiet der pflanzenzüchtung hat eine sehr lange tradition
Vielen von euch sagen vielleicht die erbsen von gregor mendel etwas
Er hat die vererbung von eigenschaften an die nächste generation erforscht
Also wie sich das erbgut verhält wenn die eltern verschiedene eigenschaften haben aber tatsächlich haben auch schon die menschen in der steinzeit
darauf geachtet welche pflanzen besonders
ertragreich oder auch besonders resistent waren und haben diese pflanzen miteinander gekreuzt
So haben sich die wildpflanzen von damals zu den heutigen
kulturpflanzen entwickelt die zuchtziele von heute sind schnell zu
Definieren und sie unterscheiden sich eigentlich nicht sehr von den vergangenen immer geht es um höhere erträge
resistenzen und bands bessere anpassungen an die gegebenen umweltbedingungen
aktuelle forschungsprojekte tüfteln beispielsweise an besonders
ertragreichen weizen an maispflanzen die trotz großer trockenheit viele früchte tragen oder auch an
bananenpflanzen die raupen verschmähen es könnte neben ware
superhelden der pflanzenwelt gezüchtet werden mit ganz bestimmten und
extremen eigenschaften und hier kommt chris farkas 9 ins spiel auch in der pflanzenzüchtung überzeugt die technologie durch drei eigenschaften
ganz besonders die schlagworte
präzise
einfach und schnell in der praxis bedeutet das dass sich die entwicklungszeit einer neuen pflanzensorte halbieren ließe acht bis neun jahre
dauerte das bislang dazu kamen dann durchschnittlich noch drei bis vier jahre dazu die die sogenannte sorten prüfung in
deutschland in anspruch
Nimmt durch chris packers 9 kann das erbgut einer pflanze ja wie gesagt
zielgerichtet verändert werden die gewünschte resistenz oder der höhere ertrag werden so viel schneller erreicht
Doch wie immer gibt es auch kritik und die ist sehr stichhaltig die der große streitpunkt in diesem kontext ist der sogenannte
naturbegriff ist solch eine veränderung an einer pflanze
Natürlich die befürworter argumentieren dass diese veränderung auch zufällig in der natur vorkommen würde denn setzt
punktmutationen also tatsächlich nur die veränderung eines einzelnen bausteine der dna
kann enorme auswirkungen auf den jeweiligen organismus haben die christ methode sei biologisch und keine chemie oder
strahlung
Kritiker dagegen halten den prozess der herstellung für unnatürlich also künstlich fraglich ist allerdings ob der begriff und die
argumentation der natürlichkeit passend sind dazu das bundesamt für naturschutz
zitat der vergleich mit der natürlichkeit ist dabei irreführend da eine
Höhere naturnähe nicht per se ein geringes risiko darstellt zitat ende denn?
natürlich ist nicht gleichzusetzen mit
gesund oder sicher die konsequenzen die die neu
gezüchteten pflanzen für das komplette ökosystem mit sich bringen könnten die sind lang
bislang nicht wirklich 8
zu schätzen würden die besonders stress resistenzen pflanzen beispielsweise
andere arten verdrängen manche experten und der experten befürchten dies
Welche folgen hat die technologie auf den menschlichen körper und unsere gesundheit
Diskussionen gibt es auch zur forschung in diesem bereich in einem brief von
2016 fordern mehr als 100 nobelpreis träger und trägerinnen aus verschiedenen forschungsgebieten
das grüne gentechnik in der landwirtschaft
Eingesetzt wird ja es könnte den welthunger ja vielleicht sogar abschaffen landwirtschaft umweltschützer sind aber skeptisch
Wir bleiben natürlich dran an diesem thema wenn er kein video dazu und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesse nicht den
Genau auf die glocke denn nur dann verpasst er kein video hier geht es weiter
Mit dass große insekten sterben eine wirklich dramatische situation bei der dringend gehandelt werden muss also unbedingt ansehen und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran